let's answer some of your questions
we'll get right to it at dorian is not
gray which i am convinced is a tom brady
burner account how much action do you
think taysom hill will get against the
bears i'm going to start this one
shireen because i think back to last
year's wild card playoff game that is
when the saints unleashed taysom hill he
was the best player on the field this is
where you throw caution to the wind and
i know they've been careful about taysom
hill earlier this year and they had to
have him ready to play quarterback if
you want to win this game this is when
you put your best 11 players on the
field and you use them so i think we're
going to see a lot of taste some hill
against the bears
well he played 23 of 56 snaps against
the vikings last year in that playoff
game i think it'll be similar to that
but every time he was on the field mike
he was handling the ball he had a ton of
touches in that game i think it's going
to be like that again and one of the
reasons why
you think of alvin kamar coming back
from covid you think of michael thomas
and deontay harris coming back from
their injuries they haven't played in a
while what's their conditioning going to
be like we don't know that but i would
be willing to bet that those guys might
have some sort of a pitch count i know
it's the playoffs you hope you can win
this game though by not using those guys
as much taysom hill is ready to go we've
seen it he's fresh he's good he's in
football shape i expect to see a lot of
him maybe even more than the 23 snaps
that he played last year
a red zone out who do you trust more in
the playoffs lamar jackson shireen or
josh allen who you got
i don't know that we can trust either
one of them mike because we haven't seen
it right i mean neither one has won a
playoff game i i you know i i guess if
i'm
gonna say i'll go with josh allen just
because he's had the better regular
season but that doesn't always translate
to the postseason as we saw last year
with lamar jackson it didn't translate
in the postseason so i'm not trusting
either one until they completely get it
done in the postseason and win a
postseason game and they haven't done
that yet they haven't proved they can do
it
one thing that the bills did last year
that i thought they might do when they
got to the playoffs they unleashed josh
allen as a runner and i have no problem
with that it's those awkward moments
that we saw a few of most notably the
over-the-head lateral thing and i think
that that's something that happens when
he presses and when he doesn't have the
help around him is when he's more likely
to press he's got the help around him
now he's matured as a player he's
improved as a player i have more faith
in him than i do in lamar jackson
because for lamar jackson
we've seen it twice now spectacular
performances in the regular season and
then in the playoffs it just goes the
other way and until you can shed that
that that vibe that feeling until you
can get past that the chances of it
happening again are still there and
because it's happened twice now i think
the pressure gets a little bit greater
if it happens this year the pressure is
going to be a little greater than next
year so i agree with you i trust josh
allen
a little bit more or maybe a lot more
than lamar jackson uncle phil what's the
starting point in your opinion for a
desean watson trade package shireen this
is one that i threw out there last night
and maybe it would take more than the
first overall pick in the draft but
remember if you're trading the first
overall pick in the draft this year
you're not trading the first pick you're
trading trevor lawrence would you trade
if you're the houston texans desean
watson straight up for trevor lawrence i
think maybe you would
yeah that's tough i do know this bill
o'brien is not there so they're not
going to give him away like they gave
away deandre hopkins that's one thing i
do know it's going to take a lot more of
a package put together to to get to sean
watson
if i'm the jaguars i i probably take
that now if i'm houston you're you're
sending them to somebody in the same
division so i don't know that i'm gonna
do that that that's tough to do that in
the same division that's the only reason
i think i pause on it but if you can't
repair that bridge with deshaun watson
then you're gonna have to get rid of
them and you're going to want a
high pick plus other picks uh because
you got to find a quarterback now right
they don't just grow on trees mike
right and here's what here's what you do
here's the starting point actually
because i i'm fascinated by the
possibility of a straight up trevor
lawrence for desean watson trade
especially since they both went to
clemson what you do is you make it known
he's available and you sit back and wait
that's the starting point because you
don't have to ask for anything once it's
known that desean watson's available you
just sit back and the offers come in and
you sift through the offers and you use
one to get more from the other and you
maximize via negotiation how far
everyone is willing to go and then you
ultimately pick one and you hope that
that's a place desean watson wants to go
because i think that's part of it too
that's the real starting point because
it isn't going to be the texans
negotiating with one team it's going to
be the texans presiding over an auction
that many teams will attend if if they
want to trade him if they eventually
give in to his desire to be traded if he
does desire to be traded
they could get
a load of picks and players in return
because they will be lining up out the
door for the chance to get to sean
watson all right let's take a break
we'll answer more of your questions as
we wrap up this friday edition of pftpm
right after this
all right let's jam in as many more of
these questions as we can gong show west
with the number one pick and all that
cap space do you have any confident that
the jaguars brain trust will make the
right personnel decisions for next
season
let me just handle this one easily
because i didn't want to do this one uh
because we've already talked about the
jaguars they're trying to knock us off
the air we still got four minutes don't
take us off the air don't pull the plug
on us yet
they don't have a brain trust yet we
don't know who their brain trust is once
we know who their brain trust is then
we'll decide whether or not they're
going to screw this up let me move on to
the next one
jamon javian out of all the wild card
games this weekend which has the biggest
chance of featuring an upset by the
underdog shireen
well i think you got to go with the
titans mike just because they've proved
that they can do it they've beaten
baltimore the last two times they've
played including the postseason last
year they know how to do it
they've got the motivation they've got
derek henry and the ravens haven't shown
yet that they know how to stop derek
henry and if they can't stop it derek
henry they're not going to win that game
jack jack 9298 over under derrick henry
rushing yards in that game 150.
whoo
i think i'm going to go under but he is
going to get
over 100 yards but i think he's going to
get less than he got in the postseason
last year somewhere around the 133 i
think it was that he had in the regular
season as my guest
they have no chance to win if he doesn't
get a hundred now as i say that i am
envisioning a box score where the titans
win and he has 97 yards rushing so
i retract that statement before i have
to self-report myself to old takes
exposed they need a big day from derek
henry and he has a chance to go over 150
was over 190 last year tom g post what
would it take for howie roseman aka
jeffrey lurie's adopted son to get fired
by the eagles of course roseman the
executive vp of football operations and
general manager what would it take
shereen
well i think they're all on notice mike
going into next season with what
happened this season they expected a
better year from this team carson wentz
regressed i don't know how
any of those guys are secure beyond 2021
right they've all got to be under
pressure to perform better this year or
they're all gone
yeah i agree with you and
jeffrey lurie has fired his last two
coaches when they failed to make it to
the postseason in consecutive years andy
reid had two straight note playoffs he
was out he's
by the way spoiler alert it's turned out
well for andy reid chip kelly had a
season of the playoffs and then two
seasons without and he was gone so i
agree with you at a minimum doug
peterson is going to be out i still
think there's a oh
it's died down
but but i i i don't after what happened
last week i
i don't know could peterson be out i
don't think he is but i just wonder
whether it's sustainable and that leads
to this last question we'll take in
quite shy are we right in saying the
giants need to learn from the logic of
the eagles at the end of the last season
washington lost to the giants and that's
the difference between chase young
versus jeff okuda it pays to tank
sometimes and this gets back to and
we're going to finish the week where we
started there is a reason
for the eagles doing what they did and
if the giants had just lost to
washington last year they'd have chase
young and maybe they'd be playing tom
brady tomorrow night but it's the way it
happened in that last game of the
regular season
where we were led to believe that they
were going to try to win we saw that
tanking in a very conspicuous spot that
embarrassed the nfl and embarrassed the
eagles the way it happened so yes it
does pay but you better set it up the
right way or you're going to do more
damage
than good to yourself shireen
and you better pick the right player
mike we've seen before when player when
teams have done this and they've picked
the wrong players so you have to pick
the right player too
well there's always benefit in being
higher than lower and that's what the
eagles will try to remind everyone
between now and late april they have the
sixth spot not the nine and now they
have to make the best of it make the
best of this weekend enjoy the games
we'll see you back here on monday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports